bhindi Chandler it has finally happened
congratulations on your engagement how
are you two feeling it's the best day of
my life and I'm so excited you know
we're so perfect I mean my here at
Australia Zoo right now but Chandler
proposed um you zoom we met here in
Australia it was just beyond perfect and
I'm still speechless
it was amazing after six years together
how did you decide that this was the
perfect moment to propose you know we
really were just enjoying life and she
was always the one but it really seemed
like the stars align there's a 21st
birthday it was a big milestone and it
seemed like the perfect time to take the
next step in our relationship and do a
family photo shoot so thankfully also I
love my beautiful mom can I just add mom
the day before my birthday said to me
you're about to turn 21 we have to have
a girls afternoon let's go get manicures
so I was like okay that sounds lovely
because I never get my nails done I mean
I work with wildlife why would I paint
my nails so great having Terry in
Roberts oops I've gotten the best family
in additional this Harry has been so
supportive since day one and Roberts
always there to help out too so I got
the best family in additional sand the
perfect girl you two have talked about
knowing that your each other soul mate
how and when did you know from the
moment I met Ben the INA shoe is the
perfect girl in my life the one and we
just enjoyed life up until now but it
seemed like the stars really aligned for
this to be the perfect moment so his
Bendis 21st birth
they and we had a 21st birthday photo
shoot organized after we did all the
australian zoo festivities so we got all
ready and right before the photo shoot
Vinny and I went to a private garden in
the zoo and it was just a perfect time
to pop the question
it was the best moment of my life and
we'll remember it forever
best 21st birthday present ever Robert
was actually hiding in the bushes and
then he didn't notice at all so Robert
was hiding in the bushes and captured
the exact moment where we asked the
question so the proposal sounds perfect
but Chandler how long have you been
planning all this leading up I've had
this plan for a while so I had the ring
already and it was about a couple weeks
that I had the ring that I was waiting
for this all to line up and the more I
waited the more excited I got I just
wanted to ask her immediately but I knew
I wanted it to be perfect photos you'll
see that Chandler's holding the ring box
and Robert so cute Roberts taking all
the photos but in one of the photos
you'll see I'm kind of reaching out
towards Chandler's hands because his
hands were shaking with the Rings
genuinely I had no idea yes can you guys
take me inside walk me through the
actual moment of you popping the
question you know we were getting ready
to go for the photo shoot and I said oh
you know everyone's still getting set up
so why don't we just go for a walk have
some quiet time because we have a big
celebration at the zoo every year at the
Penny's birthday so is the perfect time
to say let's just have a moment let's
relax for a second now he walked into
the gardens and I walked to the spot
that I picked out with Robert a couple
days ago and just said now it seems like
the perfect chance will you marry me
I'm just so happy I might explode into
confetti or glitter at any moment and
what grades will have those photos
forever now so it's all captured and
we'll remember it for every year and
then it bursts out from behind worked
out bendy I know there's so much joy but
I would imagine your dad steve is on
your mind what is it like to celebrate
this milestone but to still wish that he
was here this is why I'm not talking to
you so much because you completely get
it and I think that a lot of us in life
is I've lost someone really close to us
and these big milestones are often the
hardest because that's when you want
someone there and and I think that when
when the time comes that we do get
married hopefully because I'm really
excited but I think that for me it'll be
really important that Robert walks me
down the aisle and that's something that
I I really want to do and and it's East
ever since dad passed away you know as a
little girl you always think about your
wedding day and I'm always so grateful
that Robert is there and he has been
such a big part of my life and he's
always stepped up and been the one to
you know give me a hug when I need it
and encourage me forward and like so he
will definitely be the one to walk me
down the aisle when the time comes and I
think that that will make it really
special and I think that's what Dad
would have wanted as well I think it was
it was genuinely a bittersweet time so
you know in the moment it was so
incredibly special but then at the same
time but for me on a personal memory
there's there's people who I've we wish
could be here today for this time in my
life
and particularly dad I wish that he
could be here to be getting excited and
to the family and I think that's really
challenging so it's it's kind of one of
the happiest times in my life and also
one of the most challenging Mindy how do
you think your dad would have reacted to
Chandler and to him being the one who
has taken your heart I think that dad
would have loved him very much and he
would have been so excited that he's now
hot about family and the fact that I
found my person in life is just so
wonderful and mom and Robert were all
giving me hugs and dads best mate and an
Australia Zoo
where's Mannion he was there as well
when we were all getting photos together
as a family and he was saying how proud
and excited dad would have been to so it
was really special to have that that
feeling that dad was kind of with us in
a way exactly
yeah it was kind of that bittersweet
moment but I'm just my mom sent me a
text that evening after we had announced
everything and I was getting ready for
bed and she texted me and she said are
you I'm so proud of you and I'm so
excited that we welcome children to the
family but she said no one would have
been more excited than your dad and he
would have just cried a day and I assume
it's that's so special because you know
everyone looks at at who is the
strongest person in the whole world and
yet you know when whenever I would
accomplish something big in life from
the time I was a little girl he would
always cheer up and I remember being
tiny and I've started filming thing to
the jungle Gowen he would watch him film
and then he'd get a little bit
teary-eyed and I think that it was
really special hearing that for Mom that
you know out of all of us dad would have
been probably most exciting that's
wonderful I wish I wish so much that he
could be here to revel in this time but
I suppose in a way he is his spirit
lives on in all of us and I could
definitely feel his just his energy on
the day
he's always with us Chandler did you go
by tradition did you ask Terry and
Robert for their blessing before
proposing and if you did how did it go
so I wanted to ask Terry and Robert and
we've been a family for six years so
they feel like failing - me too and
they're just the most supportive people
in the entire world they have your back
no matter what so I really wanted to ask
them but also make that special - so I
said how also in the Australia Zoo
Gardens a nice picnic blanket with
cheeses and fruit and everything and sat
them down were having a nice picnic and
cuckoo birds were coming in and we were
eating them and I asked them you know I
really love bindi she is the girl of my
dreams and I'm so blessed to spend my
life with her and I really want to ask
you guys permission to marry bindi and
immediately they were so supportive than
getting the biggest hug and said welcome
to the family and it was really really
special we've all been running around
filming different stories Joey's I'm
like go and catch up with you mommy so
how long is all this been in the works
when did you ask Terry and Robert and
when did you start working on the ring
the longest process was actually finding
the perfect ring so I wanted to find one
that represented everything summed up in
the her positivity the way how she's
old-fashioned and district ring so I
asked Terri and Robert and then actually
had their help and choosing the ring you
guys have been together almost six years
I'm guessing you had talked about what
kind of ring you wanted and getting
married we actually did I think I think
my my biggest thing that I said to Chan
there is I really want if you ever get
the chance to get a ring I really want a
lab-grown diamond so channa found this
beautiful ring and it's made from
recycled rose gold and the
laughs grunting and it's just it's
perfect so it made me very happy and it
does have a little nod towards my life
with it's twisted band kind of nature
inspired so it's alright so you guys
have mentioned quickie wedding I gotta
ask when are we thinking where what's
the vibe how many people I'm thinking I
want to get everything ready this year
and then beginning of next year 2020
sounds perfect so I do have to say of
course it's going to happen at the zoo I
mean we met at the zoo it's where we
work and we love we love what we do we
got engaged at the zoo so it only seems
like the perfect place to have a wedding
so it'll definitely be at Australia Zoo
and timing that's a really good question
I mean regarding game show Parks and
Recreation these guys always tease me
that I am truly know so I'm getting out
my binder it's a few months away because
I have to make sure everything is
perfect because I am Leslie Knope so
it's a few months away but I guarantee
you yes bindi we know khaki is not just
a color it's a lifestyle but will you go
as far as wearing a khaki dress yeah we
can all wear cocky then he's very
old-fashioned in traditional so I think
I'll be a white dress and then a hold of
the cocky end but I think for me I'm so
I think that I'd love the dress that
shows off my personality I'm always
saying that inside I feel like maybe
your old woman so many lives
one lifetime but it will be I love the
look of legs and something that's just
really traditional and special bindi I
know that your dad is always with you a
wedding such an emotional day how do you
want to make sure that his presence is
still felt I think that for me the most
important thing is is getting married
here in Australia Zoo because this is
where I feel conscious today
so there's gonna be a whole lot of
planning that goes into the wedding day
but for me at the heart of it all I want
to make sure that my mom is there that
my brother's there and that it's it's a
really close family event and that we
remember dad so whether it's a clip that
we play out of dad or something that
just reminds us of you there is that
moment that a lot of little girls think
about their dad walking them down the
aisle you also have things like a first
dance my brother did my first dance with
me
bindi who will be your first dance it
would be with my mom because my mom and
I are so close and and she's she's my
pillar of strength in life and I love
her beyond description so yeah I think
that when the time comes Robert will
walk me down the aisle
we'll have a wonderful moment and then
I'll have my my dances mom and I think
that would be wonderful
bindi your mother teri is such an
incredible soul what kind of advice has
she given you to throughout this journey
of strength and support throughout our
entire relationship mom has been the one
who has helped us throughout the entire
journey honestly I mean long-distance
for us because Chandler you know living
in Florida I mean Australia it was
really challenging so through it all mom
was this great strength she was always
there to offer us advice and pass on
these little pearls of wisdom and it's
the same now after getting engaged I
think mom was her special shape she said
to me a few months ago she said your dad
and I always used to talk about what
makes a perfect marriage or a really
wonderful marriage and she said what's
interest
is that for us it was kind of that
feeling of comfort so you know your
relationship can be this wonderful
exciting adventure but you want to find
someone who at the end of the day is
really comfortable with and she said for
your dad and I it was the fact that feel
kind of like an old shoes and it sounds
really weird but if you have your most
comfortable pair of shoes you can always
count on those you know they're always
gonna hold up and they'll walk you
through life and and they're dependable
and she said that's what our marriage
was it was like the most comfortable
pair of shoes and she said that's that's
what you're looking for so you can enjoy
all this wonderful adventure but then at
the end of the day you come home to
someone who you always be there for you
and who will back you up
and just maybe that confidence is about
in your life and how marriage advice is
so wonderful cuz I feel like that's what
we have exactly and what's amazing is
your parents did long-distance before
there's any cell phones or anything so
is writing letters back and forth so we
were fortunate to live in a time where
we could communicate regularly so it's
great having her advice of it all
because she had been through it with
Steve and what's really neat is in a way
Steven Terry almost brought us together
because growing up in Florida I grew up
Steve and Terry were my heroes and when
I came to Australia Australia's II was
at the top of my list because of Steven
zarion I never expected to meet the most
beautiful girl on the love month flight
the day I visited Australian spired me
my whole life and for us in other
relationships we've always looked up to
them because they have there's one thing
that we're you know life wasn't always
this perfect fairytale but they were
always there for each other
you
[Music]